Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and ahhh ha,
Ooh.
E I'm just checking in.
All mother bugging you.
Um,
uh,
what's going on?
I'm in the middle of this,
this acting job over the he,
so I got to do this before they picked me up in the sad van.
The Sad van that takes you to set for the excitement.
That's the rules.
If you're going to have that much fun pretending to be somebody else,
right.
Winning bar fights and all the shit you get to do as an actor.
All the shit you can't do in real life.
Um,
then yeah,
they got to pick you up in a sad van.
The van is basically a barebones usually all white with the gray vinyl and t
just completely like,
you know,
four wheels powertrain,
this will get you there.
I call it the said Finn.
I don't know why.
Um,
but that is the one thing about it.
Great thing about acting as you get to do all this shit that you don't get to do
in real life.
You know,
which is what's kind of cracking me up lately about action movies is how,
um,
I don't know when exactly the action hero genre started,
but I,
I came up in the 80s.
So you know,
you had
Stallone Yad Schwartzenegger,
John Claude van Damme and then you had,
um,
Steven Seagal in each year.
They try to,
you know,
Chuck Norris in each year.
They just tried to fucking,
Chuck Norris actually walk the line from like action hero in Karate Guy,
right?
He was somewhere between like Bruce Lee and,
and uh,
I dunno what fucking Chuck Norris,
I guess,
sorry,
my brain is fried.
We've been walking at work and long hours here.
Um,
but anyways,
those movies kind of already started off ridiculous.
You know,
we have 40 guys with machine guns and a guy would just fucking,
there's one movie where I think it's Schwartzenegger,
there's like 20 guys with machine guns shooting at him and there's all these
potted plants and he just runs and kind of puts his hand up,
you know,
to guard his face from all the thousands of bullets that are coming at them.
And somehow they missed some
runs across this fucking foyer.
I mean they just kept getting more and more ridiculous,
you know,
all the way up to like a Steven Seagal where he would,
she would barely be moving and just beat the shit out of an entire bar.
I love when they would throw a punch at his face and he would just sort of lean
and just actually watched the fiscal passed his face.
Um,
so now just when you think that,
you know,
and the dialogue was always really bad.
So then what they did,
you know what?
They all went away because they just got so ridiculous.
They kind of just start making action movies for a long fucking time.
I think they did anyways.
Um,
I guess the born identities and those were action movies,
whatever.
All I know is that now they got the lady starring in a and m for some reason,
like I think just because people are so educated to how fucking stupid they
were,
they actually finally decided to start writing decent dialogue,
you know,
as opposed to all this shit.
They gave a Stallone to be a a go for it,
uh,
is a right,
oh,
what's his face?
Schwartzenegger would rip off a steam pipe and throw it through somebody's chest
and then be like,
let off some steam.
I mean,
it was literally that bad
both week.
My friend,
he's dead tired this really bad.
Um,
then they started actually writing scripts and uh,
I guess the,
yeah,
like the Bourne identity.
And then you had the,
uh,
the other guy lock stock and for fucking who's amanuensis.
And uh,
so now they've got the ladies are doing them and they're actually writing good
scripts.
But you know,
it is kind of funny to watch a woman like beating the shit out of two fucking
400 pound guys.
I mean,
doesn't it get to the point where it's like,
I don't give a fuck how much karate,
you know,
like I could just sit on you.
Cause that's the latest one.
The latest ones like atomic blonde and uh,
they just got off.
They kind of pick smaller guys because it immediately takes me out of the movie
like,
Jesus,
what the fuck?
Come on.
Really.
You know what I mean?
It's bad ass.
It's those women are in the UFC.
They still fight other women because you know,
and there's still weight classes because at the end of the day,
if you're tall enough in your fat enough,
you can eat a lot of those punches.
Yeah.
Then you just,
you just smother.
I remember that like when you're old brother,
your older brother would sit on your chest and you be getting claustrophobia.
Huh?
Mom?
Like that they could just do that to you and they would,
they would win the,
I gotta keep my voicemail.
Um,
yeah,
they would just win the fucking fight.
So,
um,
I'm not trying to be a party pooper here.
I'm going to go see atomic blonde.
But it is getting to,
it's a comedy.
You know what it is.
It's a combination of those kinds of movies and then all those feminist tee
shirts that I saw this week that's really started to fucking annoy me.
It's like,
do they think they're dumb enough that they're going to get into my fucking head
with this shit?
You know,
I told you guys about that t shirt I saw,
right?
This woman was walking around with this t shirt.
It said,
um,
uh,
what is it said?
A a a little boy.
Oh,
you're a strong woman.
Scares a little boy,
but excites a man.
Yeah.
Like what kind of guy would fall for that page?
One horseshit psychology.
Like I'm going to be all I want to be.
I wouldn't be considered a strong man.
It's like,
Hey lady,
how about you say something fucking impressive that I already talked about this
already on Monday.
I can't remember anyways.
And said,
why don't you fucking say something impressive?
You know,
instead of having your tee shirt warm up the crowd.
Um,
I can't remember if I told you guys this already,
but I wanted to make a t shirt that says a real woman isn't afraid to make her
Amanda Sandwich every once in awhile just to get the looks.
See that right there ladies.
That's exactly what we're talking about.
What are you smiling about?
Nia.
You liked that one
in the same little song again?
Huh?
You sit in the same song again.
I was thinking what's same old song again?
You're saying
what is my same old song yet?
You're saying mold fucking song.
You Sang.
Ooh.
Like when women do stove and see things and have feeling you still singing that
same old?
No,
I don't know that.
So what I'm saying old man,
that's not what I'm saying.
Prehistoric cave man.
Have you evolved at all in the time we've been together or are you just singing
the same old song?
Oh,
if you'd let me finish,
I heard everything that you said.
All right.
I heard this.
A drastic tee shirt isn't a tee shirt a little ridiculous.
I mean,
if I had the male version of like,
you know,
a real woman would blah,
blah,
a little,
your take on it is actually very funny,
but
it's still,
what were you talking to?
You were talking about how,
oh,
the,
the women in the action films like beating up like big guys,
but you're willing to suspend your disbelief that vin diesel can drive a car
through.
Not One,
but two or three buildings in fact.
Oh No,
I'm not.
It'd be fine.
No,
I'm not.
And be like,
Whoa,
that was quite a ride.
Or whatever it is that he didn't know.
It's stupid.
No,
it's absolutely stupid.
They drive from one building to another fish tail before that.
It's completely stupid.
I don't watch those movies.
Right.
So I'm just saying it was all action films.
You guys suspend your disbelief a little bit.
Daniel Craig can't beat up like 20 guys at one time.
No,
I've been to the movie.
He does know.
Yeah.
But here's the thing.
What they did was,
what they did was they started in the 80s and it was immediately ridiculous in
the dialogue was horrific.
So then what they did was they started to may have better dialogue and it
actually had the guys get hurt a little bit with like,
you know,
fucking Bruce Willis had his bloody foot on the glass and his wife Peter just
kept getting dirtier and dirtier.
So they tried to make them real.
But I'm just saying when I was watching that atomic blood,
she's like beating the shit out of these two guys.
They're like 260 pounds each.
So skies.
Yeah,
once they get their paws on you,
I don't give a f if you,
if somebody outweighs you by a hundred pounds,
once they get their hands on,
he is fucking over and there's two of them,
but it's a movie,
so we go with it.
Right.
I know,
but it just gets too,
there is a certain level,
like there's a bunch of them.
Like,
I never used to watch the Bourne identity just because the way they would edit
it.
I went to one of them.
I swear to God I almost had a seizure.
Yeah.
The editing was like,
uh,
that was that,
that,
that one done.
A Woody Harrelson did,
uh,
the murderers of the boyfriend,
girlfriend,
murderers.
Natural born killers.
Yeah.
The way that was edited,
it just,
it was just like,
you know,
this is fucking,
I can't,
I can't watch this.
Right.
Then the quick cuts.
Yeah,
but that's what you're talking about.
You're so bombarded with images.
I get it.
Slow the edits down please.
Right?
Yeah.
There was one,
Matt Damon was like fighting a guy inside a bathroom in like his elbow would go
back.
They follow that through the wall and then back to the guys head.
It's like cheese.
It's fucking Christ.
You know,
if these NFL running backs are like,
can't even move until Tuesday.
The level of fighting that this guy would do on just like every six hours.
Oh my God.
Wait,
did you see that video?
Speaking of NFL running backs of the ex NFL player who ran through that plate
glass,
that glass door and his wife thinks he's suffering from some like you know,
post traumatic stress in his brain.
It's called something CTE.
Did you see that video?
He know,
but I'm trying not to laugh.
He had literary sprints through a glass or when he doesn't remember doing it.
Don't love itself.
It is definitely sad,
but that is fucking hilarious that he's just like walking into a dental office
and all of a sudden he just,
he is 60 49 woo woo.
Said,
Huh?
I'm just fucking fun.
I can run through it.
No,
that should there it's ruining their brains.
Like isn't that like what are they going to do?
What are they going to do with,
did he spike his wallet after he went through the window?
No,
because he fell down after he crafted the glass.
As long as he just walked in with his wife and all of a sudden he just fucking
mid conversation.
He was talking to police or something about something.
Maybe he was having some sort of episode and then he just took off and he ran
right through this.
Like Glassdoor.
I got it.
Okay.
Grocery store.
Was he black or white?
Black.
All right.
He's talking to the cops.
Yeah,
there's probably some shit from his childhood.
You can't blame the NFL Dick.
I thought the cops don't treat you guys well.
He
ran through a glass door and he doesn't remember doing it.
So his wife was like,
I think he's got,
his brain is all fucked up from playing football.
So where are they going to do about that?
Can they put more padding in the helmet or like how?
No,
cause what Hap,
what it is is your brain sits in fluid so it's going to take some fucking like
crazy brainiac to have like something that somehow keeps your brain stationary.
The helmet fucking moves,
but you had,
doesn't see your brain doesn't smash against it.
I mean,
personally,
if I was Oj Simpson's lawyers back in 1994 that's what I would've said.
I would've said Oj suffers from CTE.
He had been watching the cooking channel or this Ginsu knife commercial and he
just got a little confused.
Well,
whatever you want to Ron Goldman,
look like Vince Ferragamo and he never liked the ramps.
I mean that's the best I could have come up with.
Sure,
sure.
Well,
it's a comedy podcast.
If you bring something up,
what am I supposed to do?
No,
I'm laughing.
Okay.
On the inside.
It's an inner cry Bitch.
Um,
yeah.
Did you see that?
You want to see,
okay,
now if we're going to just talk about horrible fucking things,
did you see that,
that fear,
that carnival out there and I'm in Ohio with somebody went on where like one of
those tilt the world rides in the fucking thing snapped and all these poor
people went flying through the air.
One person died.
This little girl was laying on the ground is one of the most horrific things
I've ever seen.
And then like investigators are looking into to see what the problem is.
It's like,
you know what the fucking problem is?
They don't maintain those things.
I used to,
uh,
I used to go to that a,
I don't want to,
I don't get in trouble here.
Uh,
it rhymes with seven in a homophobic slur.
No,
no.
I should say I'm going to do one,
six homophobic slur.
You don't know that one.
You used to go to a wet,
what do you weigh?
What does it,
what is a,
was a country wave flag.
Yeah.
Oh yes,
yes.
So I went there and
so I went there,
seven banners,
banners for seven brothers.
Why can't you say where it was you think they're going to like,
not want to?
I made it happened.
I was at the ones in that rhymes with a ring wield massive two sets and um,
I go to,
I was,
I was on the roller coaster,
right.
And uh,
we got off it and the time it took us to stand in line and the ride next to us,
we lined up,
you know,
the line moved twice.
We just heard Bam.
And the rollercoaster that was ending,
the ride did not stop and rear ended the ride in front of it.
And this woman broke her cheekbone.
You remember the time we went to that other one that rhymes with the six
homophobic slurs,
um,
out in a new war Z and we were,
we were in that superman roller coaster and we got like,
we were waiting to get off it and then it would move and then we were stuck in
those things.
Yeah,
it was really horrific.
How many minutes?
30 minutes.
No,
it wasn't 30 it was probably like four minutes.
Five minutes.
30 minutes.
Might've been like 10.
But I was sitting there and I felt you started to freak out.
And I was like,
well,
if I want it to,
I could wiggle my way out of it.
And the second I couldn't move.
All of a sudden I started feeling shortness of breath and I was like,
hold it together.
Bill holds it together.
Definitely.
We actually went to that place.
I assume that was my idea.
I don't think he would ever suggest going to a theme park as a date.
And you didn't,
you weren't you?
The one that taught me that a macaroni and cheese is not a main dish.
Yes,
I was.
I'm,
I'm this weird combination of,
you know,
professional white collars and white trash.
Oh yeah.
We weren't good with money.
That was a period we were not good at money,
so we used to have a tray.
A macaroni cheese would toast.
Yeah.
It's fucking delicious.
The craft frozen.
You just throw it in there.
God,
how dare you.
You know that white people are the enemy.
Agel really cheese.
It's pasta.
It's from Italians so you can only take 50% of the credit.
Stallions will be offended that you use Kraft macaroni and cheese.
Wait a minute.
I times do they make macaroni and cheese.
That's not their thing yet is macaroni and cheese.
That's one of the immediate Italian,
that's one of the first things that they say when they meet them.
No,
you want some macaroni and cheese?
Maybe beef on toast.
Now remember we can allocating,
I made fun of me because I was like making a jet and we went out to dinner the
other night and I was sort of like lovingly doing this kind of like,
no you weren't.
It was because,
because we were in,
okay.
First of all,
when I'm on my podcast and I'm just being silly now,
if you did what you did in little Italy the other night in the,
in this apartment,
I would have laughed.
We were sitting there,
right?
I took Nia to we,
we got this restaurant when I first met my lovely wife,
I took her to like 10 years ago.
Right?
So I'm trying like all day go.
Yeah.
Saying let's whatever saint,
let's fucking go there.
She's like,
oh,
I want to go to the stone cold creamery and fucking uh,
what's that other stupid burger place that everybody eats?
Like it's crack.
Let shake shack shake shack like this and say,
I want to go to shake shack over this.
Anyway,
whatever.
Just tell the story.
We go,
you want to,
she wanted to go to some shiny place and I wanted to go to the fucking old
school.
Homestyle you know,
in order like chicken Palmer's Sean.
It's like,
is that it does that,
how long did you hammer this?
That this is only one chicken processes,
like nine chicken breasts and then you fucking plow your way through it.
You wish you didn't need it,
but it was delicious.
So we'd go there and they're playing all this Italian music,
right?
They got Dana One when the moon hits your eye,
like a big pizza applied at so more.
And then Nia does,
you know that thing that you know in Hollywood movies,
one of the Italian,
like something when he puts his thumb between his index in his middle finger,
brings them together with both hands,
like Glenn back and forth,
back and forth like that.
So good a pizza sauce.
So the songs on and Nia starts doing that at the table,
sticking a bottom that Butler g you book a book book in a fun wigs and bounce in
louder the music.
They were playing
[inaudible] Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And I was like,
you know,
I was just doing the whole,
and I said,
nick,
what if we were up in Harlem and some soul food restaurant?
Okay.
And they started playing some fucking RB or whatever the fuck you guys are
listening to.
And I started to doing a bad version of some break dance and shit.
Stick at my bottom lip out.
You'd be like,
if you don't stop fucking doing that and you're sitting there with a white man,
Nia.
Huh?
What,
what do you think,
what do you think would happen?
Saying just show,
hey,
it was out of respect.
So with culturally insensitive of me to do that,
I didn't give a shit.
I thought it was funny,
but I didn't need the waiters.
We still hadn't gotten all of our foods,
so I didn't need you fucking with our food.
They had the whole rack of glasses and stuff like right by the window,
like rent behind.
We were sitting,
I mean,
come on,
can I ask you a question if I took you to Chinatown was delicious though by the
way.
Deletional ish.
Delish now if I took you to Binga leash,
if I took you to Chinatown.
Okay.
And they would play in the,
you know what did did that,
that,
that that day we went in because apparently that's offensive.
Okay.
Have you started playing high ya Ya,
Ya,
Ya know,
if fewer,
if they started playing some,
everybody was Kung Fu fighting.
Yeah.
What would you,
would you be doing?
Hey girl.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Start doing.
Everybody was counting who find it there will be offensive.
Abby.
Yeah.
All right.
I mean,
I don't know.
I wasn't,
I really wasn't,
I'm not trying to be political correct guy.
I'm just trying to get people not to spit in my food.
That's all I'm trying to do.
Talking to the waiter like a by that I'm bringing some aid fucking Vinny
[inaudible] like I was thrown into that shit.
Like I was on the fucking Sopranos.
I wasn't doing that.
All right.
I mean,
your,
your point is a maid.
Yeah.
My point is not about being culturally sensitive.
It's about having people not fuck with your food.
Okay.
You want to do that on your own.
Your own time.
You want to go on and get a Bagel and be like,
Oh hey,
they with a lady,
you gotta get an everything Bagel like you never had before,
if you know what I mean.
They're not,
I mean everything.
[inaudible]
is that a month's of boulder?
Um,
anyways,
uh,
well I don't have to wrap it up cause I don't,
I like the way we've been doing 20 minutes.
Oh,
I got to read some.
Ah,
I gotta read some,
uh,
advertising advertising sometime,
but I know I'm not supposed to because why aren't you supposed to?
Because they want you to read the advertise.
No one's no one's paying for me to read it.
They want you to read it.
Yeah.
Everybody knows that.
When did she have to bring that up?
I know,
but I'm just saying I want some weird woman thing trying to mind.
Fuck mean to get,
yes.
That's it.
You can put it on a tee shirt.
Yep.
[inaudible] Yup.
It's a great one.
The chief hold on me.
The other night we were laying in bed and all the lights were out and we both
tired and there's a lamp like across the room sitting there.
She's like,
how do you turn that lamp off?
And I'm like,
I don't know.
Nia,
you get up,
you walk over and you turn it off.
Like,
Oh,
I'll show you.
How dumb do you think I am?
I am dumb.
I'm not that dumb.
Pena.
Go take some karate classes and beat up all my tall friends.
I want to see that.
All right,
the Tux.
Everybody.
Um,
see you see this idea.
This is another progression for your people.
What are you talking about?
He used to just back in the day.
He's just be the white Tux.
No,
no.
This isn't one of those things.
Let's see how you can get through this.
This read.
Okay.
Nice and slow so you don't mess up.
Oh,
you can make fun of me all you want.
But you married me.
You pitched your wagon to this wasn't listened to what you finished your,
yeah.
Listen to what you hitched your wagon to the Black Tux.
You know,
there's only so many opportunities in life to wear a Tuxedo.
That's true at chunks.
A tux.
So when your big day or special event rolls around or you'd have to go to court,
you got to go to court.
That's a good move.
Show up in a Tuxedo.
Your honor.
May I approach the bench with my Cumber Bun?
So when your big day or special event rolls around this summer,
look,
just as great as you feel with suits from the black tux.com with high quality
rental suits and Tuxedos delivered to your doorsteps of delivered to your
doorstep.
Sorry,
that was all in capital letters.
The Black Tux gives you a new way to rent.
Why do you keep putting the emphasis on the cause?
I always watched football and they go the Ohio State University.
Okay,
all only the capital letter once and I'll yell at capital level noise,
right?
Plus with their frame home.
Try on's.
You get to saying the fit and feel the quality of your suits months before your
event and the best part is it's completely done online.
What fucking coke had wrote this shit?
Now this is the best word now.
That's the best word.
All right,
the black Tux dark.
The black [inaudible] dot com
lets you create your look or choose from tons of stylistics stylist,
stylist selected outfits.
Dude,
this really only like three d.
It's the black one.
The white one in the gray one suits like these.
Usually retail for $1,200 really?
But at the black Tux they start at just $95.
Why does this itch?
If you have any questions or issues,
their expert customer care team has your back every step of the way,
no pun intended.
After ordering your suit,
after ordering your suit will arrive 14 days before your event.
If anything is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a free replacement right away.
Uh,
when your event's over,
just drop your rental back in the mail.
Jesus in the mail,
you're gonna fold it.
How many times your full debt to getting that through a little slump.
People are just going to stop it until enough of or looking.
Addiction is smelly socks.
All wadded up.
Chicken Marsala stains all over
dose.
What else,
Amy?
I guess what?
Shipping is free both ways.
How easy is that stand out at your event for the right reasons with the black
Tux call to action to get $20 off your purchase,
visit the black tux.com/ [inaudible] that's the black
tux.com/bar for $20 off your purchase.
All right.
Legals home,
everybody.
Come on in.
Zoom,
zoom,
zoom.
Do Remember that shown you?
Come on and zoom out.
Zoom out,
zoom out.
Zoom,
kid show.
Come on,
give it a try.
We're gonna show you just why we're gonna teach you to fly.
Hi.
Come on in.
[inaudible] come on.
And legal,
zoom,
legal zoom.
Sometimes how my time is here.
That means it's time for family vacations,
sunscreen and barbecues.
Uh,
but the most important thing to do this summer is prepare for your family's
future with an estate plan from legal zoom.
Exactly.
But if the Hibachi blows up in your face there,
and next thing you know somebody doesn't have a flat,
sorry,
national make a will month is right around the corner.
And that's the perfect time to make sure you're prepared for the future.
How do you,
who do you have to pay off to have the month be about you?
You know,
when they're like,
today is national pancake day.
Somebody lobbies for that.
And how relieved are those senators?
You know,
usually there's some sort of pill that's literally going to fucking kill
children in some God forsaken place.
This is this next bill's about pancakes and for once people with red ties and
blue ties can all get along because who doesn't like pancakes?
Um,
it helps to know what your options are.
Legal Zoom,
zoom,
zoom out.
Zoom not is not a law firm,
but their network of independent attorneys available in 50 states can work with
you to make sure you're getting the right estate plan,
whether that includes a will or living trust.
Uh,
they'll provide specific advice to,
to address the needs of your family.
Plus during national make a will month,
month,
legal zoom,
zoom,
zoom miles,
a little,
pulling a bunch of zooms,
pulling a bunch of helpful resources together,
all in one place to make it a little easier to ensure your family and assets are
protected.
Call to action.
Keep listening.
We'll have more information in August and to find out more now,
check out legal zoom.com for special offers that are coming your way.
If you're a fam,
if you have a family,
whether you're still with them or you abandoned them or you own anything you
care about,
you won't want to miss out.
In the meantime,
saved more money.
Save more by entering [inaudible] at checkout,
at legal,
zoom.com legal zoom.com.
All right,
mercifully we're through that.
How about the Red Sox?
They finally want to have to drop in four in a row.
They lost the last two.
The angels,
they lost the first two to Seattle before they finally beat the fucking Bareness
and the a Yankee starting to surge.
The only end game and a half up,
you know,
which is crazy because there's only like 50 games left.
Um,
how much time have I done here?
I've got to get going.
Cause this sad van.
Yeah.
You familiar with the sad van that takes you to the set?
You know that that's even pass?
Yeah,
the 15 passenger.
Yeah.
All White Gray,
vinyl.
You know what about it?
I know,
I always find it depressing.
Why?
I always liked,
I always liked the union guy.
That means you go in a sec.
Yeah,
I know,
but they could have,
you know,
could they couldn't get like the fucking,
the cloth seats,
everything.
She's,
you could literally,
you could beat the shit out of the inside of the,
everything's just plastic.
Excited to go to your sex and the city remake your kids.
You Doing?
Yeah.
I'm playing a,
but it's an old male version on place.
Cynthia Nixon and she trans,
she's transgender.
She always,
she always related male and uh,
somewhere during the best actress on this,
you know,
it's great if you transition from,
oh no,
wait a second.
If you transitioned from woman to a man,
yes.
All right.
Can you go bald,
dead?
Maybe like if they start giving you a male hormones,
I don't know.
If you get the good hormones,
can you be like,
listen,
I want the fucking,
and who's kind of,
who's got the great full head of hair?
Who said the Kennedys always had great heads of here,
right?
Yeah.
Like you get the Kennedy Gene,
I don't know hormone.
Can they do that yet?
That's one arena I'm willing to step into.
I'm not,
I'm not willing to step into that conversation cause I don't,
I don't know anything about why because I'm not saying they can't join the coast
guard.
Well,
Trump did.
I know.
That's what I'm saying.
Oh yeah.
This is the joke.
Okay.
Sorry.
Um,
isn't that a good thing though?
No.
Who the fuck cares?
I wish he banned red heads from going to war.
I'd be like,
Whoa,
my man,
I'm voting for you again.
Hey,
could you vote for me now that I don't have to pay taxes,
how about that?
Oh good.
I don't have to go down to some godforsaken bootcamp and get screamed at by some
fucking guy whose mom never hugged him.
I get it.
Where I'm from.
Livestock into homosexuals are from,
I understand sir.
Wow.
Look at all the extra stripes you have on your shirt versus mine.
Why in God's name I want to go do that
to get a free pair of timberlands.
I would definitely be that guy.
If I was in the military,
who at the end of my hitch,
whatever the terminology would be,
I would definitely be the guy who takes apart his weapon.
It starts to mail it home,
bolt by bolt.
That's why I didn't join.
I would do some dumb shit like that.
I try to figure out how to take apart a grenade so I could be the hit at the,
at the 4th of July party.
Um,
alright.
What do we got here at 29 minutes and 54 seconds.
All right.
I'm contractually obligated to do 30 seconds.
I mean 30 minutes.
Um,
so,
all right.
Uh Huh.
Contract.
I have a contract with the people.
Oh yes.
I have a contract.
I told them back in 2007 that I was going to make podcasts and great again.
Hey,
hey.
We should think about how much money you think Obama is making tonight.
Let's see.
Oh Dude,
he's got it.
He's,
he's got a tour that's bigger than Kevin Hart.
Actually.
I don't think he is.
I think Kevin's still make it more,
he is a $69 million toward,
he's doing great giving Rah Rah speeches to corporations,
you know,
thousand points of light.
He's getting his bribe money near him.
And what's his wife's name?
Penelope.
How dare you?
Her name is Michelle.
Michelle.
I know she tweeted so much.
I should have known what her name was.
Don't ever disrespect Michelle Obama.
Yeah.
Why do they try to act like the wife or the guy who was actually doing the job
is so God damn important.
No,
I don't understand that.
All around the world.
Same Song.
Huh?
Who's Martha Stewart Dayton.
I Dunno what the fuck he does was the last I've heard Stedman say something on
Twitter.
Huh?
I'm telling you those ladies,
they got their bitches in line.
I'm just fucking around.
Hey Nia,
do you want to make fun of my hat before we go?
Oh my God.
Okay,
so let me do this.
Let me get,
no,
no.
I'm going to tell back story.
Bill fucking bought
a Sassy Midwestern mom,
New York tourist hat.
And it's the most ridiculous that I can I please take a picture of you in to eat
it.
Yes.
But this is what happened.
Um,
as bald is Charlie Brown actually he guys at one curly cute thing and uh,
the sun was out tomorrow,
the sun was out and I just,
it was just fucking a Hot New York day and I didn't have my hat because I
fucking worked out with my Nike hat and I needed one because,
uh,
I actually used to think you have,
I'm so pasty that if I got a little bit of Sun that would be good.
But it's bad.
Yes,
it's bad cause you come in and yeah,
I come in red and they're like,
what the fuck do we do with this?
Uh,
so I had to put a hat on so I didn't fuck up my Cynthia Nixon acts acting gig
here.
And uh,
so you know,
all they have this time of year is they just have all these New York City had
some down in the village.
So I was in a bind and they didn't have a mirror and I bought it.
And it's like literally,
you know those,
you know those shirts,
Jay Leno,
where's with the gene gene?
It's a denim hat.
It's in a mat,
no New York City hat.
And it's the kind of had that a white Midwestern mom would wear.
Be like,
Ooh,
I gotta I gotta I got a hat from,
from New York City,
let kids,
I got a hat,
like a baseball hat.
Like you guys have.
Like,
that's exactly what this is.
The woman on set was making fun of it.
I said,
how awful is this?
Had?
She goes,
it's pretty awful.
I go look at this cool t shirt.
My wife bought me.
I go and I just ruin it with this hat.
And she goes pretty much like she was giving me no day.
Like she wasn't,
there was no out,
nothing.
Alright.
We'll put all through the [inaudible] podcast will tweet out a picture of my
awful hat.
Yeah.
Um,
all right.
Fuckos enjoy the music.
Uh,
transitioning into a,
some,
an extra 30 minutes here of a greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast from a Thursday.
Yeah.
I knew that went by but is no longer here,
but we'll never be forgotten.
[inaudible]
and a lot of fire hose.
See Shit
to give it another shot.
Moves Holly started Oh carefully from
becoming something that,
that uh,
stay
[inaudible].
Yeah.
[inaudible]
Hey,
you know what people wanted me to talk about Jay z and Solange or oh,
the elevator fight.
Whatever the hell are fucking name.
That's a name.
I'm sick of Jay z wearing that.
Roger Moore Tuxedo.
We get it.
You're fucking cool enough already.
Tom Ford.
Oh,
is that what that is?
Yeah.
I fucking know.
I always feel at this point,
Jay z so famous.
You forget he's from Brooklyn and he fucking grew up in a street corner.
Can still beat the shit out of you.
You know,
although him with his shirt off,
you know,
I don't know.
He's definitely a businessmen either.
Yeah,
exactly.
He's,
he's fine dining.
He's eating like steak and wine and like croissants.
He is not keen.
90 action.
I could tell you that I need to do all,
he's got the gift of Gab.
He doesn't need to do all it doesn't,
it doesn't.
You know what I've,
I've had enough arguments that people,
God bless him and his Roger Moore Tuxedo.
Did you talk the,
the elevator fight?
Have you come?
I'll talk about it.
Oh,
Right.
That hotdog,
I thought Jay Z,
regardless of whatever the fuck he said that set her off showed unbelievable
restraint.
Okay.
Getting kicked by a woman in high heel shoes.
I've been there.
Okay.
That fight,
it fucking hurts.
And he kept taking it to the hands and there was a moment at one,
I only watched it once.
There was a time,
like one of the last times she hit him,
she even flinched cause she was like,
yeah,
at this point he decided to deserve to get punched in the face.
You see her flinch,
she spit at him.
That was what was really awful.
That's what I forgot to do to that driver this morning.
That would have been going at him.
Browning bitch moved.
I never do that.
No,
no,
no.
But you know,
their family has problems like anybody else's family.
I feel like if anything,
it just,
you know,
it just goes to show you that you shouldn't feel bad when you know your uncles
or whatever starts screaming at each other over thanksgiving.
That is funny though,
when you really think about how many people are toured judging them.
Actually there's footage that exists somewhere of their family fighting in an
elevator.
It's just they're not famous and nobody cares.
Yes.
So it's,
it just gets taped over.
Yeah.
I feel like a lot,
there are a lot more like physical fights that happen in families between
siblings and stuff that most people wouldn't want to admit.
You know?
So it's,
I,
it's,
I really don't think it's that big of a deal.
I will watching it,
like salons stop.
He definitely said something fucked up because Beyonce did do anything.
Yes.
She was with her sister.
She was probably like bio.
That's what happens when you say x,
Y,
and z.
That was her vibe.
Uh,
yeah.
So,
but I,
it's not that big of a deal.
I don't feel like,
you know.
No,
that's kind of a big no,
that's a def that's,
that's over.
Their relationship is fucking over.
Eh.
If money wasn't involved,
whose relationship?
Jaycees and uh,
the fucking large.
Yeah.
No side kick there.
She's not as she is.
Come on.
She's frank.
Frank Stallone.
No,
no.
She has a really good album.
I love her music and she has great style.
No,
she does famous as Beyonce obviously,
and all these dumb ass Internet people on Twitter.
Like I've never even heard of her until knows.
You should be thankful she got any consistent,
this is my,
my theory because you don't know music beyond what's on your top 40 radio
station.
Hey,
play in the morning while you're going to work.
Doesn't mean that this person isn't talented.
No,
I just get annoyed with cheese first.
The vegans down the music lovers,
this is the deal.
The only way she can make it is if she's in the same group is Beyonce because
that's the way it fucking works.
There's no way.
Never in the history of two people in the same family trying to be as solo
artists.
Have they ever made it.
They always,
you got to be together.
The Everly brothers,
the Jackson five,
the Osmonds.
And then what happens is if somebody breaks out of it and then the rest of them
go back to the dinner table going,
I have an album out to whenever he's like,
yeah,
we don't care.
I know I'm your mother.
I don't care.
Michael is special.
Donny and Marie are the best.
They're younger than you.
They're cuter than you.
And Jesus likes them better.
And that's what happens and you're fucked.
So the only move she had was when Beyonce was on the way up.
She should have been in Destiny's child.
Look at me,
look at me on the other side of the fence.
Just calling off groups here.
Bill.
She was well machine.
That group.
She was like a bad,
it was Tim with holes and a that chick from a call from uh,
uh,
the one on the roller skates.
Tootie wasn't sure that
it is his name and black people now.
Yeah.
Um,
no,
she was like a backup dancer.
She went on tour with them when she was younger.
She had an album when she was younger.
She got pregnant.
She moved on to like,
I was in Oklahoma,
somebody as a backup dancer.
I was remember that ACDC,
that ACDC video.
Who made who when I add all the Angus is up there.
I was,
I was one of the Angus.
She also,
she also didn't really people I didn't know.
I wish I did.
Hey,
she also wrote quite a few of Beyonce songs.
I'm like call road.
Some of destiny trots on it too,
so you know she's,
she's got other talents,
things,
you know.
Yeah.
She doesn't need to be as famous like that.
She's like that chick and I say,
Hey Linda Berry.
No,
her name is Linda.
Power isn't,
no it isn't she the leads is it Jessica [inaudible] you know I'm right.
I don't know what her name is.
Four non blondes.
Yeah.
Lead singer Linda Perry recently married to Sarah Gilbert from Roseanne.
Did you know that you could play Darlene?
They're either married.
The last time I saw her at Linda Perry,
not the last time like I see her,
but I saw her four non blondes chick.
Isn't she like fuck she's gotta be my age probably.
What's she going around at that little girl for?
What are you talking about?
Sarah Gilbert's older than I am.
I saw the show the other day.
She's like 12.
That's cause she looks great.
She's joking.
Like I was watching the fucking TV show here.
I'm just bombing all over the place.
[inaudible]
wow.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill bar and it is the Monday morning podcast for a Monday,
July 27th,
two south 2009 2000 2009 and uh,
uh,
the year of the content,
I can never remember what year it is.
And the Chinese knew it's,
is it the year of the pig?
I think it is the year of the pig,
isn't it?
I saw a thing the other night where,
you know those shows where they have people,
they flip houses,
they buy some dilapidated Hunka shipped from some old lady who just died when
she fucking passed out face first and her fucking dog food cause it got damn
backers killed her formal referral.
One K.
Right.
Do all people have 401ks do they have that back in the day when they were buying
war bonds and my dog sleeping over there,
look at her fucking adorable.
Um,
anyways,
um,
yeah,
I was watching this thing.
We know they flipped.
I hate those shows where they flip the houses because uh,
you just see people getting completely fucked over.
You get a couple of shitheads,
they don't even know what they're doing.
And then they go in there and they,
uh,
they go to Grossman's all around with some awful hardware store,
home depot.
They go down there and they buy a bunch of cheap tiles and then everybody walks
in like,
oh my God,
it's beautiful.
Look,
look at the tile work.
And it was like done by this fucking accountant,
you know?
Hey,
do they know this old house?
Like it's the guy gave a shit about the house now that they should just,
they just showing people getting fucked over.
I can't stand that when people walk in and then they think that the place looks
amazing because they changed the brown paint to read and that opens the room up
or whatever.
Fucking mind trick they used and it's still the exact same piece of shit house.
And these guys sell it to these fucking morons for an extra 40 grand when all
they had to do was buy a bucket of paint,
you know?
You know what that reminds me of?
I hate those commercials now where they're trying to make it seem like fast food
is at the level of a five star restaurant and they get these white trash fucking
idiots and they just see a tablecloth and some cloth napkin.
And then they bring in some pizza hut and they're eating their pasta.
Have you seen that commercial?
And that girl was like,
oh my God,
it's so decadent.
Who the fuck uses that word when they're talking about pasta?
It's decorated.
You know?
It's like,
did you just want to use that word?
You dumb fuck.
And then they come in,
they're like,
Oh,
it's pizza hut.
It's pates.
Uh Oh my God,
I can't believe.
And I eat that shit every week,
you know,
always tasted like shit.
But now these fucking,
and he had kids.
Oh my God,
he's so fucking jacketed.
And they're breeding and they're breathing.
They're not using condoms and they're eating pasta.
I mean,
how do you know the,
and I like how,
um,
all these other fucking fast food places are acting like they in day invented
these mini burgers.
You know what I mean?
Like white castle doesn't exist.
I'm really waiting for white castle to sue a jack in the box or any one of these
other places.
These,
these guys who come up and they call them sliders and evidently it's,
it's not as fattening because rather than than eating one burger,
they take a burger and they cut it into three little ones.
But because their little,
even though you're eating the exact same amount of fucking Burger,
you know,
somehow it's,
it's,
it's less fattening.
I Dunno.
Yeah,
man.
So much.
What I just said is,
you know,
obviously just not even research,
but you know,
I,
you know,
I just,
it I,
that fucking lady using the word decadent just really annoys me.
You know,
what annoys me even more,
I can't even give you a fucking definition for it.
What does it extravagant.
Is that what it means or is that Latin for,
oh my God,
I can't believe this shitty pasta tastes much better with cloth napkins.
Is that what the fuck it means?
You know what?
I'm going to look it up right now.
I'm looking up right now because I'm gonna set you guys up with what this,
this,
this week is going to be all about.
This is going to be,
there's a lot of information,
not information this week.
Um,
that's going to becoming a,
how the fuck you spelled decadent.
D C.
Deca a,
another.
A deca.
No.
D.
E.
C.
A dent.
Deka Dent.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
That wasn't even close.
Was a d.
Wow.
Fuck.
I got it.
Holy Shit.
All right,
decadence.
Let's go to Wikipedia.
God knows they're fucking credible.
Um,
decadence can refer to a personal trade or to the state of society or a segment
of it
used to describe a person's lifestyle.
MMM.
It describes the fuck happened just in,
but goddamn computer users grab a person's lifestyle.
It describes a lack of moral and intellectual discipline.
Well there's a fucking left turn
on our way.
Yeah.
Wait a second now.
That's,
I guess gotta be right night.
Am I going to question these people?
I'm a moron.
Bill.
Why don't you just read it and shut the fuck out.
All right.
I will.
Used to describe a person's lifestyle.
It describes a lack of moral and intellectual discipline or in the Oxford
Dictionary,
a luxurious self indulgence.
Okay.
Yeah.
You know who the fuck describes pasta is a luxurious self indulgent,
you know some,
you know who does some stupid white trash conduit fuckin macaroni and cheese six
days a week and all of a sudden you bring her a little fucking Ziti and you know
she can't,
she can't believe it.
Oh my God,
it's so deck.
And she was actually,
that was an insecure comment.
They probably had an extra couple of forks there and she started to panic.
You know what I mean?
Just like Jodie foster when,
when he,
she's talking to that dude and silence of the lambs and he can tell that she,
she grew up dirt poor because of her shoes.
Right.
You know,
that's all the end of that commercial needed.
Was somebody saying,
I can smell your comment.
That would've,
that would've been all right.
You know,
I'm really being crude right now and I apologize,
especially after last week,
that video that I told all you guys to see,
I've got a lot of,
I've got a lot of feedback about that one,
about what a ignorant more on I am and uh,
I'll be reading those a little bit later.
Look at me foreshadowing here.
He like that.
Like I'm on a God damn radio station.
Um,
all right,
let's get to some,
um,
if you new to this podcast,
I do one of these every week and this is basically what it is.
All right.
If you think it's going to get better,
like I'm building to something,
I'm not,
this is pretty much,
I'm going to flat line the whole week and I feel like I have internal hiccups
right now.
You know those hiccups where you start to hiccup but then you don't.
Huh?
Am I doing an eighties bit again?
What's the deal?
Wound here goes,
um,
great.
It's like a fork.
Does it know where to go?
Oh God,
I'd love to fucking do stand up in the 80s was so much easier,
wasn't it?
One week you're an accountant.
The next minute you're on comic strip live wearing in the same blazer that you
wore when you were doing somebody's taxes,
except you just fucking pull the sleeves up and everything was funny back then.
All right.
Uh,
let's get onto some shit here.
Bill,
just for your information,
the guy,
the wrap you were trying to talk about last neat,
nice week.
[inaudible] it's pronounced.
I still can't say his Quali I'd never heard somebody say it to live.
Quali coyly I don't fucking know what his name is.
Quietly.
I mean,
I listen to someone's rap,
you know,
I like about the guy who doesn't say his fucking name every three seconds and
the one time when I need somebody to do it,
he doesn't do it.
I still don't know how to say it.
This guy spelled the Q u a how do you say?
Is that choir?
Quasi,
right?
That's how you said,
so
Kuala Quali to live quietly.
Ah,
this is fucking pathetic.
When do I do alright,
you know.
Alright,
plowing ahead here.
Um,
here's one that somebody actually was going to have,
uh,
for another segment,
but this seemed more like a ask bill.
Uh,
here's two things I'd love to hear your opinion on drugs and double dates.
Um,
yes.
This guy wants to hear my opinions on double dates and this,
actually,
I think this is more of an ask bill kind of question.
So he says,
long story short,
I met the hottest chick ever at a club.
Dude.
I met though hottest fucking chick ever.
Her name's fucking Stacy.
Um,
I get a number when gonna read this all like I'm a fucking knasis's back in the
day in Kenmore square tools.
Go down a fucking knasis's with our fucking z cavalry cheese.
Dude.
Fuck it.
Go around there.
Get a couple of rule fees.
Drop them in a fucking Zima dude.
Fucking cock sucker.
All right.
Ah,
long story short.
Me In the hottest chick ever at a club.
I get her number,
we talk,
we,
I ask her out,
she changes it.
Okay.
Ask her out and then she changes it to a double date with their sister.
So I go out on this double day to an extremely expensive restaurant.
I'm 22 in college broke.
I drop $140 on her.
Uh,
the,
the sister wouldn't let me out of our sight and all I got was one small kiss
later on.
I did not even get a kiss goodnight because the sister was watching.
All right,
dude.
Now you really shouldn't be asking my opinion on double dating.
What this is really about is how did you as a young man,
22,
I'm going to cut you some slack here.
End Up in that situation.
Okay?
Don't walk away from this.
Just go in like,
you know what you wanted to do.
Overrated.
Underrated,
overrated.
Fucking,
you know,
double dating.
It sucks.
Now you should have right there to do when when she tried to turn it into a
double date right there,
you just have to be now I don't want to do that.
And she'll be like,
why don't you want to do that?
And you'd just be like,
I don't like going on double dates.
Why not?
Because one person ends up not having a good time,
and it's usually the other con that you bring.
You can clean this up.
This is
no,
you know what I mean?
You get your,
you just just say it.
I swear to God that we know when you're 22 you don't realize the power of no.
All right.
It actually seems like maybe you have some shit going on because at 22 most guys
don't know how to talk to women.
So all women here is yes,
yes,
yes.
Especially if they're hot.
They just keep fucking agreeing with them.
So if you say no,
all of a sudden it's,
it's,
it's kind of different.
I mean,
you could fuck it up,
but at the end of the day,
dude,
you didn't get laid and you're out 150 bucks.
All right?
Think about that moment when she said,
let's turn.
You were,
you know,
going to turn this into a double date.
What did your internal voice say?
Oh Great.
Or did it say,
fuck,
this is going to suck.
This is going to suck.
I'm not going to be able to get along with this girl.
Uh,
you know Joe Pesci,
I'm trying to fucking bang this brought over here.
You know,
it's not going to go good.
So right there you just got to work.
You just got to say no,
I don't want to do a double day.
And she'll say,
why?
And just say,
cause I'm 22,
what am I potsy we unhappy days.
We're going to go to inspiration point.
You want to go out on a date with me?
I don't show at that point you bring a little anger into it and you kind of just
show the side of your head and you don't really look at her.
That'll get you.
That'll get you a second tape.
All right.
That was fucking brutal.
That was bad advice.
I'm trying to tell you,
dude,
just don't fucking go on a double date.
All right.
They suck.
You knew they suck.
You knew before I even went on it,
you knew it was going to suck.
And if you're broke,
don't take a girl to someplace where you've got to drop 140 bucks.
You know,
what did she do to deserve $140 meal?
What?
Cause she's hot like that some sort of accomplishment.
She was born that way.
You know what you did is you basically took probably a nice girl and you just
added another layer to the foundation of her.
Just being an incredibly stuck up human being who doesn't have,
who doesn't have to develop a personality.
You know,
look at me making all these judgments.
But I think it's true.
Just because your heart doesn't mean you deserve $140 meal if you're broke,
to be honest with yourself with that chick was like a seven.
You know,
you'd probably take it a pizza hut for some fucking decade in Pasta.
So I don't know.
Did I help you there?
I got to stop doing these podcasts on Sunday cause I'm fucking jet lag from
flying back to wherever the fuck I came from.
I was actually working in Denver this weekend.
I was at the comedy works.
So I should take some time here to,
uh,
um,
thank everyone who came out to see me.
The turnout in Denver was ridiculous and I actually flew in a day early and I
got to do five minutes out at red rocks.
And,
um,
if you're not from Denver and a,
you're not a fan of youtube,
just go on youtube and just Google red rocks.
It's fucking,
it's one of the most amazing venues is basically an outdoor venue built into the
side of a mountain and that youtube video,
speaking to that.
Yeah,
that's what I was trying to say.
That youtube video.
I don't what the fuck was called unforgettable fire.
I don't know.
What was it about?
What was it about me?
What do,
what does youtube sing about?
They sing about breaking up with girls,
Martin Luther King.
And uh,
then they went through their irony stage,
didn't they?
Where you were the big glasses and he just ain't just acted like everything was
fucking surreal.
I don't know.
Whatever it did.
There's a video that they did way back in the day and he marches around like,
what the what the fucking flag?
Like he's in a,
I don't know,
like they're doing something.
He playing like this military be get 10,
10,
30 to 10 and did that.
And he comes my,
I'll say it all fucking David spade bit.
He starts chatting.
No War.
There you go.
It's that video.
Yeah,
no,
we got it.
It's not like they're a small fucking indie band.
We knew 10 minutes ago when you started describing and I right.
I right.
Sometimes they get a little carried away.
I,
uh,
just reminds me of something.
Can I had a falling out with somebody like two months ago.
You have somebody,
a friend of yours,
just say something so fucking stupid that you don't even get angry and you just,
you just have that moment like,
wow,
I can't be friends with this person anymore because they're a fucking moron.
You know?
You know what happens?
Somebody,
somebody that's happened to me twice.
One time somebody said,
uh,
they were talking about secretary at that horse
and they were talking about all the,
all the races,
the horse one and in the end they went,
what an athlete
and uh,
I dunno if that was it.
I just could never look at them the same way.
What an athlete,
you know,
I,
I just do,
I have,
you need to fucking go off on that.
Do I need to explore?
Can you tell them actually scrolling down,
I'm trying to find something else.
Somebody wrote a fucking question about that.
This whole fucking podcast,
it's just falling apart.
This is what you get.
You know what?
Maybe if I started charging for these things,
I take them a little more seriously and we wouldn't have these long lulls and my
dog's fast asleep from my monotone voice is no,
there's no passion in this.
What am I doing here with a fuck?
Is it,
you know what?
Fuck this podcast.
Am I going to start over?
I'm not gonna Start,
you know,
I want to plow through.
I can't,
I can't start over.
This is it.
I got one take.
This is like live television here.
I'm just going to read everything in front of me.
How about that?
All right.
Uh,
Bill is,
listen to your podcast on a July 20th.
You said,
uh,
the,
that the youtube video,
tough talking college girl was a must see a surge forward.
Oh yeah.
That people kind of took it down.
People took that one down.
Um,
and if you didn't see it,
that people keep putting it back up.
So just check every couple of days.
Just look up search,
tough talk and college girl,
t,
u,
F F and it's talking with the Ge even though I don't pronounce my gs.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
here's one for your ps.
My girlfriend and I were at the grocery store last night and all that they had
opened where those self checkouts,
this is the first time I was put in that situation because they usually always
have at least one real lane open.
Anyways,
the place was fucking swamped and go into a real person to pay for the shit
wasn't even an option.
Uh,
there were three fucking employees who's just three fucking employees.
standing there.
I went up to the three Fox and I asked him if,
uh,
if they would open a real lane and they just told me that they were too short
staffed,
um,
fucking horse shit.
This guy says,
he said,
I thought to myself,
uh,
where is bill burr when you need them to do,
what would I do other than just sit there and curse under my breath now next to
some fucking candy.
Like you did fucking bullshit.
That's fucking bullshit.
Um,
so I got in line and I rang up my own shit,
like a little pitch.
Uh,
I had no other option.
What,
what you done in that situation?
Um,
I would have done exactly what you did.
I would have been hostile towards the three people there.
I would have cursed under my breath and then I probably just would've fucking,
you know,
depending on how much I needed the shit,
if I really didn't need this stuff,
what I,
what I would've done a what I would like to,
you know what I'm doing right now,
I'm doing that shit.
You know,
we're after something goes down and the guy tells you the story.
Then there's always that Douche bag.
He goes,
dude,
you know what I would've done?
You know what I would've done?
Now that I have all the fucking information,
um,
you know what you could do in the future is just say,
oh,
well then I'm going to come back during the day when you have some people and
then just leave your food there and let them put it back.
You know,
do it.
I told you this was going to fucking happen.
They're understaffed.
They're understaffed on purpose.
That's phase two.
Phase one was just to have like five or six fucking registers and gave you three
others.
So all the fucking sheep look over the curiosity factor,
what's going on.
And then you had the other cashiers over there teaching them how to fucking use
it.
Now they've gotten beyond that.
Now they're going into phase two.
Okay?
Phase two of the experiment.
What happens if there's no,
if there are no cashier people,
how will the herd handle this?
When should we do it?
Well,
we can't do it during the day.
There's fucking old people and their little motorcars riding around.
Let's do it later on at night.
Let's see how the drunk crowd handles it.
Even if they don't like it,
they won't fucking remember.
At the very least.
They won't send any angry letters.
I'm telling you,
this is how the whole fucking thing's going to go.
And somebody actually asked me in this,
uh,
this week asked me,
they were curious as to what I thought about htms.
Um,
yeah,
I'm not against technology is if it makes my life like easier,
like ATM at banks before,
I don't know if you guys remember this ship to back in the day when there was no
ATS,
you know,
Friday five o'clock.
If you didn't grab the cash you needed for the weekend,
you are fucked.
You couldn't get to you my IC,
they will be open for like 20 minutes on a Saturday.
But uh,
yeah,
that was just be that,
that their expression,
the guys work in banker hours.
He used to be open like nine to five.
He can never even get your fucking money out.
So what I like about the ATM as at least I have access to my money.
I don't mind that.
And a lot of times it is easier to just throw it in there so I don't give a
fuck.
You know that one doesn't bug me and I understand the technology does replace
some jobs.
The reason why I can't stand this latest brand of automated shit is it's not an
advancement.
It doesn't make it easier.
I just go up and do exactly what the cashier did and the bag person did,
except I'm doing it for free.
Now.
If I walked up to the cashier machine,
the automated thing and magically the fucking thing figured out what I owed and
then suddenly it was all in a bag,
I wouldn't give a shit.
All right.
I Dunno.
People just hear what they want to hear.
Like you make one comment about something,
it's good.
I don't like technologies against penicillin.
Now I'm not,
I'm not at vent gets advancements.
I'm against fuck overs and those automated things in the grocery store and at
the f,
the the parking garage,
the automated park or fuck overs.
It doesn't make it quicker.
It actually makes it longer and a lot of instances.
And uh,
I'm just working for free.
I'm working for free and I don't fucking like it.
Okay.
And that's the last time I'm fucking explaining it and I don't need any,
you douchebags Oui.
They wing in my origins.
The other Gainey winch quicker.
You're a moron.
Just fucking work for free.
All right,
here we go.
Um,
what are we going on to?
Somebody sent me an email,
said,
hey bill,
I just want to thank you.
Uh,
thanks a bunch for teaching me about tinnitus.
That's that ringing in the ear stuff I was talking about.
I just turned 21.
I had that shit as long as I can remember.
Didn't know what it was a thought.
It was just me,
um,
for anyone that has the problem and not sure what to do when I was younger,
I used,
uh,
I left the TV on.
That was a bad idea.
After that I played,
uh,
mostly chill music and my music collection and a seven minute album or something
like that.
Now I just sort of put a fan on low speed and it keeps the ringing your way for
those of you who don't have tonight is what he's saying is,
is you put some sort of smaller,
quieter noise in the background that drowns out the ringing in your ear and uh,
actually do what you really should do is go see a doctor is what you're supposed
to do.
And um,
I don't know.
Um,
that's,
I think the cases of Tinnitus is going to go way up just because of like iPods.
And when you go to clubs,
how loud they play that fucking music.
Um,
actually,
you know,
I,
I actually bring earplugs everywhere I go because I have such fucked up ears,
at least I try to remember.
But basically how it works is anything up to about 60 or 65 decibels,
you're pretty much cool.
And you can listen.
Your ear can handle like a right around 60 decibels that say,
ah,
that's like how I'm talking right now.
Regular conversation and you,
you don't do any damage to your ears.
Your ears can listen to it for,
you know,
all day and you don't do any damage.
But what happens,
I forget how the math works,
but every time you move up 10 decibels,
like 60 to 70 the timeframe that your ears can listen to that level of noise
without doing permanent damage goes down really quickly.
And I know some worry where when you start getting around 80 that starts getting
dangerous and anything above 90 um,
I mean I think like 90 listening to something at 90 minutes.
Don't quote me on this.
I forget.
I used,
I used to have this chart and only shit I tried to find on the Internet but I
couldn't.
But anything around 90 decibels after like 15 minutes.
And you can easily with an iPod go up to about a buck 10 15 minutes of listening
to music.
You do permanent damage to your hearing.
And I know that sounds fucked up.
It's just incremental.
And you can't tell,
I forget,
I read all this shit.
There's little hairs in there and when you blow it out,
the things get knocked down and then they slowly stand back up again.
And after a while they just don't get back up again.
They just fucking like a boxer.
They just lay in there and you go into clubs man.
And they have,
they have those dead fucking music up to like a buck 15,
a buck 20.
If he noticed the bouncers who worked there always have ear plugs for the most
part.
Um,
I dunno,
I suffer from tonight is you don't want it.
It's horrific.
But um,
if you have it,
you should definitely go see a doctor and I would always have earplugs on you
just in case,
you know,
you're hanging out bay,
it's check out this bar and you go in there and I don't know why they play the
music that fucking loud.
I can tell if the,
I guess if there's a Dj and there's dancing,
but when you just walk into a bar and you having a couple beers and he got to
scream,
I can't fucking stand that.
I don't know.
Maybe because I'm,
maybe because I'm old.
Who knows.
All right,
let's move on to the next section here.
I'm just,
I'm just reading shit this week.
All right.
I Dunno why I forget what this is,
but this section is named the accidental racist.
All right.
Uh,
hey bill,
I just downloaded a bunch of your uninformed shows on mini mini Nova and just
began listening to the first one,
a show from February 10th,
2007 I stopped at three minutes in to write you to thank you for delivering
already the accidental racism to the Asian guy.
Oh,
that's why this name is,
I'm in the elevator story.
It kind of reminded me of a sending semi funny thing that happened to me.
All right.
Just to get you guys caught up,
I was going up in the elevator at the old,
uh,
XM building evidently on February 10th,
2007 and it was me and Joe de Rosa who do the show.
And there was this Asian guy in the elevator and I can't remember what,
but he seemed confused.
And,
uh,
he was,
I,
I sometime I didn't know what floor he was on.
Somehow I made the assumption that he was delivering food and I conveyed that to
him and I was,
yeah.
Said something like,
Oh,
what are you delivering food?
And he just put his head down and he goes,
I work here.
And I felt like such a fucking asshole.
But he just looked,
he looked disheveled and he was dressed down.
We did the show on a Saturday,
so he wasn't dressed like he was going to work.
It was just one of those things.
Uh,
if I could find the guy,
I would apologize to them.
But you know what I mean?
There are a lot of Asian guys delivering food in,
uh,
in New York,
you know,
so,
and they're always going up elevators and they always have that local,
like,
what fucking floor am I going to?
I don't know.
The Guy,
I don't,
what happened,
they began to argue with his girlfriend.
It's how I read it.
So anyways,
I felt like an asshole and I apologize,
uh,
if for some reason he's listening to this podcast to be funny,
if he actually was a listener of my podcast and didn't realize that was me and
now realizes it's me and now I've lost another listener.
Um,
anyway,
so this guy I guess has a story just like it.
Um,
so when he says anyways,
um,
my junior year in college I was looking for a roommate because some previous
people I had lined up dropped out on me in the last minute.
A girl I was friends with put me in touch with the guy she was friends with
because,
uh,
he was looking for a place to,
despite both of us having this girl's a mutual friend,
we never met each other.
Uh,
we set everything up over the phone and came to terms we could both live with
without ever even a meeting in person.
Um,
thus the first time we would meet was at the place we would both be living in
Jesus.
Dude,
you're really taking a risk there.
Um,
there are some things about me that are vital pieces of information in order for
this story to make sense.
First of all on black.
However,
due to the tone and the pitch of my voice,
my usage of correct grammar most of the time,
um,
you know,
do it.
If I said that I would really be in trouble,
but you can trash around people.
Okay.
So everything's good.
Um,
you said I was an English major,
but I'm not an asshole about it.
I promise.
Uh,
correct grammar.
I use correct grammar most of the time and the semi racist nature of most people
,
uh,
many people have told me that I sound white or could be mistaken for a white
person over the phone.
I'm going to address that point a little bit later.
All right,
so getting back to the story.
When I talked to this kid over the phone,
we found out we had both gone to the same high school for a year.
Again,
despite that this,
we didn't know each other.
Um,
the fact that this school was mostly white combined with the sound of his voice,
I thought he was white in my mind.
Um,
which set up this awesome situation.
I figured he was guessing I was white for the same reason I was guessing.
He was,
I was really looking forward to seeing this white kids squirm when he pulled up
and realized that was black.
Of course a black kid pulled up to the house looking for me and it was a,
my prospective roommate.
I remember seeing a little bit of surprise look on his face and I said to him,
he thought I was white,
didn't you?
And then of course my computer craps out.
He smiled and admitted he did.
Uh,
I told them that I thought he was white as well.
We both ended up having a great laugh about it and became pretty good friends
afterwards.
Um,
anyways,
thanks for the podcast.
Okay,
let me,
uh,
let me get back to that.
Um,
the salmon racist nature of most people.
Many of people have told me that I sound white or it could be mistaken for a
white person over the phone for the life of me.
I don't know why that is considered racist.
Okay.
I Dunno if you've noticed,
but like white people kind of talk in a certain way.
I mean if you watch def def jam,
we just talk in one way,
but like you know,
there are,
there is
okay.
You know,
if,
I mean if I was on here and all of a sudden I was like,
Yo,
you know what I'm saying?
Doing more fucking podcast is shit.
He'd be like,
why is bill trying to talk like he's some black dude from the ghetto?
Wouldn't you?
Would that be racist or you know,
there's,
there's nothing wrong with a,
what the fuck am I trying to say here?
If you just say somebody sounds white,
you're not,
you're not saying they're a a moron.
Right.
Am I a fucking idiot here?
I don't understand why I was saying,
you know,
over the phone.
Yeah.
You sounded like a black guy or hey,
you sounded white over the phone,
is it,
does it go back to that correct grammar thing that the black person that assumes
like,
Oh,
why?
Because I didn't say motherfucker every five seconds.
I know I do a brutal fucking impression.
Um,
but it,
is that why it is,
that's actually an interesting question to say,
is this a great fucking podcast through my,
my stupidity.
You guys learn shit unless you already know it and you're rolling your fucking
eyes at that place and you have to,
if that's the case,
go fuck yourself.
All right.
And then this guy also ends this email.
He says,
uh,
what did he say here?
Anyways,
thanks for the podcast.
They're awesome.
And as a New York Yankees Fan,
I want to thank the red sox for keeping first place warm for us.
Good luck with David.
I can't hit anymore.
Now that steroids are banned or teas and Jason,
we had to trade one of the best right handed hitters of all time for this
nonthreatening white guide bay for the rest of the summer.
We know you got a lot of balls as a Yankee fan bringing up steroids.
Okay?
Half your fucking team got busted.
Do I really need to go through the names?
A Rod,
Sheffield,
GMB,
Clemens,
Pettitte.
You're a fucking $200 million team and you're on steroids.
Okay.
At least our steroid guys are fucking winning championships.
Your bunch of cons.
No,
I'm sorry.
You want it 99 in 2000 with your steroid guys.
You know I love how a Yankee fans are talking.
You got a $200 million team.
If you're barely play in 600 baseball,
you know that's like having a fucking Lamborghini and your psych that's going 70
miles an hour.
You guys should be playing like seven 20 ball with all those fucking guys you
have.
And you know what the funny thing is?
You still don't have a bullpen,
so you're not gonna win shit this year to joke.
You know what?
You guys get like a super group.
You know,
why don't you just signed fucking Ted Nugent to place play center field?
hey,
we're just
$122 billion team that could,
that's the best thing about Manny Ramirez going out to La is that it knocked our
payroll way the fuck down.
Now we're down to like 122 million.
We're actually number four this year.
People were behind the Yankees,
the mets and uh,
who was at the cubs or the Dodgers?
I,
I came.
Not the Dodgers.
Who the fuck was it?
Maybe the cubs.
I don't know who it is.
All I know is when number,
we're like 80 million less.
And this guy's all excited cause they're two or three games ahead of us.
Even though you're ona against the red sox and he got swept by the angels.
How,
what are y'all excited?
Cause your feast and on the royals in the rangers and all that Shit.
And Jason Bay is a great fucking baseball player and uh,
he's done,
been doing a great job for us and that we've barely missed Manny.
I hate to say it,
I love the guy.
And uh,
just for the record,
he didn't do steroids till he got to La.
You know,
dude,
when did he get caught?
He didn't got caught when he was in Boston that whole fucking time.
All of a sudden he comes out to la.
He starts running with the wrong crowd.
You know,
happens to the best of them when they come out here.
Look at Red River Phoenix.
He came out here.
He did some roids.
He fucking never got up again.
Cute little actor.
You was all right.
Here we go.
Here's another thing.
I don't even why I'm reading this and I'm just going to read it.
Dude.
I can't believe.
Um,
you didn't notice that she,
okay,
wait a minute.
Wait.
Okay.
Here we go.
Wait a minute.
All right.
What am I doing here?
All right,
this is,
this is the response.
One of the responses I got from that leg sweep video last week.
If you're new to my podcast,
there's a video up on youtube.
I guess it got taken down where a,
this,
this guy hits on this girl.
She doesn't,
you know,
she's not having it,
so he gives a shit.
She gives him the finger,
he calls her a bitch.
She throws a drink in his face and he goes up,
you think he,
he's going to bless her in the face and he just gives a leg or her fucking leg
sweep that I,
I it should have been done in Mandalay Bay in Las Vegas was fucking tremendous.
All right,
here we go.
So,
uh,
this,
this woman wrote me,
she goes,
uh,
Bill,
I can't believe he didn't notice that she was visited with violent behavior
first.
This is the girl in the video.
Um,
cause I was sitting there saying,
I thought the video was funny because the girl threw the drink in his face and
even though you should never hit a woman,
I just think that's outrageous in life to think that you can throw a drink in
somebody's face.
I just know if I did it within two seconds,
I would be on the ground getting fucking pummeled.
And uh,
I dunno,
there was just something funny about it.
So anyways,
she goes,
I can't believe he didn't notice that she was visited with violent behavior
first.
Watch it again and you'll see him violently poke at her.
All right.
First of all,
how fucking hilarious is that violently.
Have you ever heard that expression in your life?
Violently poked.
There's no such thing as being violently poked.
All right.
It's called stab.
That's,
you know,
that's fine.
I actually,
my gym teacher used to violently poked me in the chest fucking cock sucker.
Um,
he did and he gave her,
he gave her a little fucking poke.
He get her at one time there were fucking shoulder.
That was it.
He was just trying to annoy her.
But anyway,
she says,
by the way,
it's not very complimentary to a grown woman to be shown that he has a crush on
her by punching her.
He didn't punch.
He didn't punch her.
Anyway,
she goes,
I can't believe you're not allowing her to do the only thing she can toss a
drink.
Adam,
since she can't beat him up,
do you honestly believe that her throwing the drink equals his,
um,
kick slash knocked to her on the skull?
Shame on you.
You bastard.
So I wrote her back.
I said,
I knew this would a spark,
some debate.
I respect your point of view on it.
So here's mine violently poked 41 years on this planet and I have never heard
someone being violently poked.
Um,
she threw the drink in his face because he called her a bitch and then she goes
that cause she goes,
that's right,
I am a bitch.
And then the drink his throne and throw in the drink in his face was not the
only thing she could have done.
She could have walked away.
She could have talked to whoever was in charge at the pool.
She could have talked to some of the guys who are over there,
um,
by her friends.
There were a bunch of things she could have done,
but she lost her.
Cool.
Um,
and if you're going to,
um,
define the action by the guy in the video as violently poking her,
then you could also address,
could you also address the racial undertones of her giving the man the finger
and stating,
do you understand this in English?
The reason why the video is so funny is because the unexpected happened.
He actually treated her the same way.
He would have treated a man that threw a drink in his face.
So the reason men find the video funny I think is because the amount of times
women get physical with us and there's nothing we can do except get punched,
slap or have a drink thrown in our face because we're never going to hit a woman
and they know it.
I had a girl tried to punch me in the face and a bar and as I'm trying,
as carefully as possible to defend against getting punched in the face.
Basically I'm turning my back and covering up.
Was this girl wailed away?
The bouncer comes flying over.
And what do you think?
Who Do you think they grabbed and tossed up?
Um,
I was in an argument with the female,
but so what people are you but because of the way things are,
she can take it to a physical level while I have to try and defend myself
without getting physical with her at all,
only to be dragged out by the neck.
Uh,
you know,
if they tossed her out too,
I would've been fine with it.
But because she's a female,
she gets to throw punches,
have me kicked out,
and she gets to stay in the bar while they continue to serve or more drinks.
So to go back to the video,
um,
that is the world.
This warm woman is living in.
I'm a girl,
I can do this and nothing will happen.
I could throw a full drink in someone's face and nothing will happen.
Well,
guess what?
Something did the exact thing,
same thing that would have happened to me.
And then I go on to say,
actually I would have been fucking punched repeatedly in the face and the dude's
friends probably would have jumped into.
And you know what the reaction from the others people at the pool would have
been?
Well,
you threw a drink at his face.
What did you think was gonna Happen?
And then I guess my excuse would have been,
but he poked me violently.
Um,
anyways,
I've never had a woman aid on advocate a that game.
The video is an animal and I wouldn't want any woman I cared about to ever date
him.
But the leg,
the fucking
leg sweep was genius and undeniably funny to me.
I'm just gonna read you all these back and forth.
So then she goes,
you have no idea of what women have women have to put up with.
All right,
this is where I guess I'm a moron.
These guys take such personal offense when they're turned down,
he should have walked away.
I will not tolerate being touched by a stranger in that way.
And it is re a really vulnerable feeling as a woman.
It makes us angry and fearful of men.
Besides,
you didn't hear the things he was saying,
guys like that.
Parentheses in hip hop style clothing are the sleaziest of scumbags licking
their lips.
Nasty.
Who's hitting on you?
Ll Cool J,
why don't you fucking go to a nicer place anyways?
Uh,
as for the argument you had in the bar,
you didn't specify.
Now she's talking to me.
This is classic line.
Here she goes.
As for the argument you had with that woman in the bar.
You didn't specify what it was about,
what,
what it was about,
and if you are yelling in her face,
as you know,
you probably were.
Dot Dot,
dot.
More violent behavior.
You see that?
Let's stop right here.
This is what I love about this type of shit.
Anytime there's a group of people bitching about their situation,
nine times out of 10 when they're bitching,
they end up doing the exact same thing to the person that they're bitching at,
that they don't want done to them.
Look how you assume that immediately I'm getting hit.
I'm not hitting her back.
I'm getting hit and you're blaming me.
I'm surprised you didn't ask me what I was wearing.
Was I asking for
anyways,
you want to hear the story,
sweetheart?
This,
this is basically,
this is why this girl was punching me in the bar.
All right,
we're going back here about 10 years.
I'm standing up now.
I'm going to tell this story.
My dog's looking at me.
What's up Cleo?
How you doing?
Huh?
You're a female.
You can defend yourself.
You fucking psycho.
Um,
this,
this is what happened.
I was in,
I was in a bar and I was with somebody in mind.
This group of girls is next to us.
We're hitting on them.
You know,
we'll make jokes with joking around,
you know,
he tried to get women to laugh.
That's what the fuck you have to do.
Women,
I know you don't,
you don't understand that because you don't have to make somebody want to fuck
you.
Okay.
The same way,
I don't know what it's like to have to carry a fucking living thing inside of me
for nine months.
I understand.
We all have our advantages,
so whatever,
I'm not trying to be a Douche here,
but this is basically,
it's,
so we're trying to,
you know,
we're joking around or whatever.
I had a couple of drinks,
they had a couple of drinks and one of them was dressed like,
she looked like Rhoda on Mary Tyler Moore.
Right.
So at one point that girl goes up and uh,
she goes to go to the bathroom.
So I say to a friend and go,
Jesus Christ was she,
she a big fan of Mary Tyler Moore or what?
Right.
Made a joke about what she was wearing.
So another 20 minutes goes by,
those girls Kinda peeled off,
you know,
we weren't really talking to them anymore.
We were,
uh,
well maybe we kind of were,
I don't know what was going,
sort of that type of shit.
You're talking to a girl for a couple seconds,
then it's not working out.
So I went back,
I was talking to my friend and I guess when the girl came back from the,
from the bathroom,
her friend told her what I said.
So unbeknownst to me,
so I'm sitting there talking to my buddy.
Then all of a sudden I just hear this,
this,
this woman yelling,
hey bitch,
hey bitch.
Right.
So I look over and she's looking at me.
She's going,
hey bitch.
And I'm,
and I'm,
I'm trying to process cause I,
you know,
typical may,
I said some shit,
I don't even remember what the fuck I said.
And then she goes,
you know,
you're going to talk shit about me when I'm not around.
And then I,
then I kind of was right as I'm putting it together.
Then she stood up and she fucking put her hand over it.
You ever see like a,
you ever see like a,
a center in the NBA how they fight or they can't throw fake fucking throw
punches like that?
They're trying to fucking throw somebody out at second base.
That's what she did.
She winds up and she's about ready to come down on the top of my head.
So you know,
because she wound up,
I mean,
if she fucking threw a jab,
she would've fucking blessed to me right in the face.
And I gotta admit that would've been fucking hilarious.
But because she went up and over,
I was able to get my arm up in time and I sought,
I sorta like cut her wrist.
So now I instantly,
I recognized the situation.
I'm like,
Oh fuck.
Okay,
this girl is not going to stop and I don't want to get hit in the face.
I can't squeeze her risk too hard.
All this shit's going through my head.
And I know,
even though I can't see it,
I know the bouncers are on their way over and I know what the fuck's going to
happen.
So all I'm doing is holding her wrist as she's fucking Klein at my side.
I'm sort of turned to the side and of course my buddies aren't doing anything
that's sort of just looking at this point,
cause it happened so fast and I'm going,
Whoa,
whoa.
I was going,
hey,
hey.
I can't remember.
I was saying I was just,
just too much shit was going on.
I,
I couldn't,
I couldn't formulate anything to say to get this girl to stop,
but she just kept fucking bitch.
You fucking bitch.
It was like punching me in the side and then the fucking bouncers come over and
they fucking grabbed me.
Of course,
because I'm the guy.
I just blew my mind.
I,
I'm fucking,
I almost have my back turned to this girl with my hand up and she's wailing away
and they immediately go to me and I get fucking tossed out.
You know?
So let me ask you this.
In her world,
was she justified for taking it to a physical level?
Because I fucking made fun of her outfit.
You know,
that was my point about that video.
I don't think that you should hit a woman.
Really.
The reality of that video that I,
that I watched,
they're on youtube,
is that they're both assholes and they're both stubborn.
And what happened there is what you saw when you get two stubborn people who
want to get the last word in.
Okay?
He had Sonor,
she tells him to go fuck himself.
Not since she literally said that,
but she basically says now,
so he couldn't handle it.
So he probably,
he starts it.
I'm gonna,
I'll go,
I'll give you that.
He starts it.
Okay.
And he wants to get the last word in so she can't let him.
Right.
He should have walked away,
but he didn't.
That's,
you know,
right in the beginning he didn't.
So he gives her shit.
Then she should've walked away,
realized he was a psycho.
She doesn't,
she fucking gives them the finger than he should have walked away.
But he doesn't,
he pokes her.
She should've walked away then,
but she doesn't,
she fucking throws a drink in his face.
He should have fucking walked away.
He doesn't,
he fucking goes up and he likes sweeps or it's just one of those deals,
two fucking assholes who probably should be breeding and make a little fucking
asshole kid and then we'll have another dog.
The bounty hunter.
Huh?
You see how that math works out?
So anyways,
um,
I,
you know,
I don't know.
Sometimes I feel like I'm saying shit and people don't get what the fuck I'm
talking about.
I'm not saying that you should go around hitting a woman.
I'm just saying,
you know,
guys should never hit women,
but women shouldn't take advantage of that by doing outrageous shit.
Like throwing a drink in somebody's face that is fucking outrageous behavior.
And be honest.
As a female,
if another female walked up to you and threw a drink in your face,
what would you do?
Huh?
What would you do?
Would you just go,
oh,
that was mature?
Do you feel better about yourself?
Is sprite is dripping down the fucking your bangs?
Whatever fucking
you got that Rachel Bob Haircut from friends.
Huh?
Look at me.
Look at me with that fucking check reference.
Um,
whatever.
Uh,
it gives a fuck.
Anyways.
All right,
here's,
here's some videos.
So I actually was,
I nominated that video for a video of the year and a,
so people sent me some other videos and I'm really upset at myself because
somebody sent me a great video of these two bullies attacking this guy with his
girlfriend and his,
the guy's girlfriend jumps in and she fucking blast this guy in the face in the
end.
It's a fucking awesome video.
Um,
so I,
I really need that video so I can balance it out.
So,
you know,
so I don't just have videos of guys knocking women down because,
uh,
that's not what I'm trying to do here.
You know what I mean?
This is supposed to be a fun thing for everybody.
And,
uh,
all right,
so here you go.
Here's some nominees.
Uh,
somebody,
uh,
oh and a fan said a ace freely was in,
I was on the show this week celebrating Jim Norton's birthday.
Um,
and he recommended a video called Winnebago man.
I watched it.
It's fucking hilarious.
Um,
Google how to spell Winham Winnebago.
I'm just going to tell you what the name of the videos are.
Uh,
there's another one,
a guy with gun confronts skateboarder,
and there's another one that says,
uh,
this is the last one.
And I deliberately put this one last because this is more in the vein of last
week's video.
It says,
guy gets revenge on girlfriend for headache.
This one's really more silly and I'm actually jealous of like how perfectly this
guy's prank works out.
It's just,
it's,
it really is a work of art.
And,
uh,
most females won't like it,
but it's,
you know,
no one gets hurt in this one.
Okay?
Nobody's head hits concrete.
Um,
yeah,
that's it.
Okay.
And if you're sick of those kinds of videos,
there's one on there.
Have a little fucking golden retriever.
Puppy howling.
All right,
go Google that one.
Okay.
That'll make you fucking smile.
All right,
I'm going to have to wind this.
Jesus Christ.
47 fucking minutes.
All right,
let me wind this up real quick.
We're talking about grenades again,
people the subject that just won't die.
Uh,
anyways,
uh,
Bill,
I missed the last couple of podcasts.
This is from a marine,
so we can all hang out here,
right?
47 minutes and let's support the troops and listened to the last few minutes of
the podcast here.
I missed the last few podcasts,
but there was,
um,
there was a lot about the military.
You seem to be interested in the military,
blah,
blah.
And I was a marine for four years and did my tour in the sandbox.
Parentheses,
Iraq.
Go on Wikipedia and type in operation Phantom fury.
Those are my credentials.
That kid you talked about on six 29 was kind of a joke.
I can tell by what he says.
So he's basically saying the other are there other military person who gave me
my grenade information is,
uh,
you know,
I guess working in a mess hall.
Look at me trying to start some shit.
Look at me.
Huh?
Hey Guy from our June 29th,
you're going to take that shit.
He's saying you don't know about grenades.
So anyways,
he says frag grenades have a kill radius of five meters.
A casualty is 15 meters casualty.
I guess that's the shrapnel.
Okay.
Marines defined,
definitely use frags when necessary.
They use flash bangs when doing raids.
If you're using a flash bang and entering a room and you shoot blindly
everywhere,
it is totally contrary.
It's a total contradiction to what you're doing in the first price.
Trying not to kill everyone in the room.
If there's bad guys in there,
you frag the fucks,
I guess that she throw the grenade in there.
And if you throw in one,
you might as well throw in five grenades aren't that lethal while they are,
but it just kinda depends.
Two guys in another company tossed grenades into the,
into a house from different directions only to have the grenades roll across the
house,
cross paths and in front of the other marine respectively.
Jesus Christ,
I think I saw this on the three stooges.
Uh,
they both dove away and Eileen and only received a minor shrapnel to the legs.
I'm more of something to laugh about more than anything.
All right,
so there's your grenade information.
Here we go with earplugs.
Getting back to the tonight is shit.
Um,
when in some nasty shit,
basically when you're in battle,
you have one ear plug in and one out.
Uh,
due to the sound resistance created by plugs in only allows you to hear a
certain range of noise.
Take one out.
And it allows you to hear the larger range of noise even after you can barely
hear out of one ear.
Do.
That's fucking insane.
That's what I did and it always worked.
So basically you sacrifice one year.
Did you switch off every other battle?
You know,
or did you just say,
fuck my left ear?
Um,
I guess you need to do that because what if you have the earplugs into
somebody's sneaking up behind you?
Good God,
thank God.
Thank God I didn't have to do that.
God bless Ya.
Anyways,
a machine gun next to an unprotected ear isn't that bad at all.
Loud is explosions.
Loud is airstrikes.
Loud rockets loud is standing next to a tank in an alley and not having an ear
plugs.
The concussion river reverberates.
And Record Shay's along the walls in the of the buildings.
Um,
I know because it happened to me when in my ears started to leak clear fluid,
presumably,
presumably from perforated eardrums.
The sound was beyond sound.
That's one of the greatest sentences I've ever read.
As far as like fucking description.
The sound was beyond sound.
It was an impact.
It felt like I was hit with a two by four across my entire body all at once.
My face and my balls hurt.
She says,
right.
That's from sound,
I guess.
I don't fucking know.
Just shut up and read a bill.
All right.
Um,
I had my one,
I had my wind knocked out.
Basically I was,
I was almost even with the barrel of them,
of the main tank gun and the fucking tankers,
fucking guys in the tank never gave us a signal that they were going to shoot.
Um,
that's what it can cost of a concussion blast feels like and it gets worse.
The closer you get and the bigger the explosion is throwing some shrapnel and
you get the idea.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
this is better than the fucking history channel.
I'm really enjoying this.
All right.
Um,
and you talked about the stress of battle.
There was one dude who was about to get out of an Aa v big armored vehicle and
he went blind,
I guess he's saying from the stress.
And then he writes,
just went blind.
He regained his sight a few days later,
but right before he got out,
he literally had to turn around and say,
ah,
I can't fucking see Jesus Christ.
Um,
as for a funny store.
Oh,
you know what that reminds me.
Have you guys seen that movie?
Uh,
the fuck was that.
I was going to tell you to watch that last week.
It was that,
it was an animated movie about war.
The fuck was it called?
I just rented it walls with walls with Bryshere.
You guys see that?
I def,
I highly recommend that.
That's about a guy who went to war and when he came back he couldn't fucking
remember anything.
So then he goes around and he talks to his former army buddies.
You know,
that's the whole hook.
A guy who can't remember,
goes around and talks to those who can't forget.
It's pretty fucking pretty fucking amazing.
So anyways,
let me continue here.
Um,
and as far as for a funny story,
um,
in war the stories are all fucked up.
It's all fucked up humor when you're over there like really sadistic fucked up
shit.
Even the nicest evangelists stick person or a Mormon,
uh,
we'll have the same humor over there.
Personally,
I found it hilarious when insurgents were so drugged up,
they would literally step out of an alley in front of a tank about 50 feet away
and just start shooting an AK 47 at the thing.
The machine gun on the tank would slowly point towards the dude and just shred
them.
That's funny when you're over there.
Wow.
This is like time life books presents the Iraq war as it's going on.
So let me ask you this.
You saying the dude,
so like hopped up on drugs,
like are a lot of the insurgents over there on drugs and why are they on drugs?
Cause they're scared from the stress of the battle.
I mean,
I can't,
I can't imagine that anyway.
It's probably the best story that normal people can relate to was when we first
took over a centrally located compound within the city of Fallujah,
um,
referred to above his operation Phantom fury.
Dude,
you were in Fallujah.
Holy Shit.
All right,
this is a great story by the way.
So hang in there guys.
I know this is long.
Um,
this was the third day of the assault on the city.
Obviously after three days,
a bunch of dudes,
um,
are going to have to take a shit at some point.
So we had to dig some trenches,
the trenches.
We're in the middle of a large courtyard about the size of a football field,
and instead of just standing over the trench like a dog and squatting to shit,
we knew we had to find something to assist us when we dropped guts.
Good Lord.
Okay.
I mean,
fuck it.
We're going to have to,
if we're going to get popped while taking a shit,
we better be comfortable.
We started searching around and inside some of the side buildings,
we found some chairs and some wooden boxes.
We cut holes in them and position them over the trenches.
Um,
the area wasn't,
uh,
what the military would deem as a,
would not consider a secure at the time.
But after eating the instant dehydrated shit meals called Mras,
which constipate you,
uh,
you having constant op operations for three days,
we hadn't,
Shah had a satisfying shit for three days after the new shitters were set up.
Guys were a little apprehensive to go out there as there were still RPGs mortars
in gunfires directed towards our compound.
You have to understand that marines and the marine corps,
all right,
this is,
this is him saying this shit,
not me.
You have to understand that the marines in the Marine Corps,
uh,
like are retarded.
Many individuals are very,
actually are very intelligent within the marines,
but the Marine Corps just makes you into a retard.
And therefore the policies within the marine corps are retarded as well.
The only thing the marine corps doesn't fuck up his combat.
This retardation is why most people realis less with the Marine Corps than any
other branch.
Well,
you have to expand on that.
So anyway,
so being the rete retarded marines,
we were,
we said fuck it.
A bunch of US strolled out and took off our kavlaars,
our helmets and flax,
bulletproof vests as well as our blouses shirts.
Within two minutes there were 10 or 12 marine sitting in the middle of a bay,
uh,
middle of this field,
bear his bones court yard,
the size of a football field with only t shirts and trousers at the ankles,
smoking butts,
chewing dip,
joking around like where we had a fucking Applebee's while there were explosions
and gunfire going off 150 meters away.
Jesus Christ,
it was Robert Duvall will fucking surfing in the background.
Actually,
he didn't surf.
He was on the beach anyways.
Um,
as we were sitting there are few civilian reporters poke their heads out of the
compound and went back in.
They were looking to see in the proverbial coast to see if the proverbial coast
was clear to the armored vehicle they were using for transport.
So basically there was a bunch of reporters poking their heads out trying to get
over to their fucking armored transport.
Mind you,
this was the typical type of vehicle with the type of armor that our unit
couldn't get at the time because ours kept getting fucked up and it was too much
of a monetary drain to give us the proper protection because our big vehicles
will get blown up every couple of weeks.
Sorry,
I'm paraphrasing cause this is a really fucking long,
um,
these business,
these people had no business being there and they knew it.
This was evidenced by the fact that they continue to poke their heads out of
doorways several more times.
Apparently they got the carer courage up because all at once,
the group of about 10 people who look like my seventh grade,
a gym class started making their way to the armor armored vehicle in there.
Gay Little Blue Helmets and vests that read press in big,
bold white letters there were visibly nervous jogging mechanically and looking
spastically in every direction as if they would somehow be able to change their
fate.
Infants,
if an insurgent decided to lean out a window and opened fire at them as they
jogged along,
we sat there half naked from the bottom down and stared at them in utter
amusement.
After a few seconds of silence,
someone shitting next to me screamed and comment.
It was like a kick to the fucking nuts.
Uh,
something snapped or reporters absolutely lost their shit.
There was one of the most beautiful examples of Darwinism in action that I've
ever witnessed.
The strongest and fastest males threw themselves into the truck first,
not far behind where there's smaller males.
They were then followed by the most attractive females who were polled almost
instantly into the end of the truck.
Um,
in last where the wingman,
wingman grenades helped in only by their own,
their own large legs.
I don't get that last sentence.
Uh,
after they realized that they were actually,
there was no actually incoming
really butchering this,
sorry,
I'm seeing double at this point.
Uh,
after they realize that there actually was no incoming,
they slowly sheepishly turned to look over at us as we were sitting there with
their balls flapping in the wind dirty as fuck while pushing out three days
worth of compacted tar and having no business being happy in any way whatsoever.
But we were absolutely all dying with laughter.
We continue laughing as they drove by and we sat there smiling and waving at
them wildly like what people do when a cruise ship leaves port.
They stared at us and complete bewilderment and just simply started shaking
their heads in a way of parent does when a small child gets a pair of new
clothes covered in spaghetti and meat sauce.
But we weren't kids and we definitely weren't dirty from eating spaghetti.
Fucking classic.
Dude,
that's a great story and I apologize for butchering that thing.
I suck at reading out loud.
Um,
anyways,
this podcast has to be over a fucking hour at this point.
Yeah,
it just turned an hour.
All right.
This has been a really long podcast with a lot of information.
Um,
this has been the encyclopedia Britannica version of the Monday morning podcast.
You guys all have a good week.
I hope you enjoyed the stories.
Forgive me for my awful reading.
Yeah.
And uh,
oh,
let me hype a couple of gigs.
I got coming up.
I'm going to be at providence at the comedy connection in Providence,
Rhode Island in August and the next week I will be at the punchline in Atlanta,
Georgia.
And after that,
the final day,
August 29th,
I'm going to be in Stockholm,
Sweden.
So,
uh,
who the fuck's gonna go to that nobody
sweet and listen to this shit.
So that's it.
That's the Monday morning podcasts you want.
If you want to know the exact dates,
please go to my website.
Uh,
it's
bill@billbird.com.
B U R R.
And please sign up for my mailing list on that.
Um,
cause I'm really starting to lose,
um,
my faith in my space.
There's just nobody left on there.
Like nobody fucking emails me anymore.
So,
um,
and I don't want to join Facebook and I don't want to tweet.
So I think I'm just going to basically maybe phase out my myspace page and I'm
going to,
wow.
Just start doing shit on my,
uh,
my website.
Mainly.
That's the plan.
All right.
You guys all have a great week.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
nope.
Cool.